so fauci
again was making the rounds on sunday
you'd think that this man in this
pandemic that's getting worse and
everyone's dying and we must destroy
everything in the name of safety and all
that you would think that fauci wouldn't
have time on sunday to you know be going
all these shows you'd think that they'd
have somebody else doing the pr
you know he's old also how old is he's
about 80 years old i think he might be
81 years old if i'm not mistaken you'd
think that they'd have other people out
there do running the public space of
this because he'd be in there you know
like in the lab doing the science thing
and he'd have the thing and he'd be you
know splicing dna and combining things
and all that stuff that scientists do
he's 80 years old um well no he still
spends all his sundays doing all of
these uh sunday talk shows and uh here
he had some advice on what we can do if
we're good vaccinated citizens uh in the
upcoming holiday season and dr faunchi
lastly we know the best way to keep safe
is to be vaccinated but what are your
guidelines for the upcoming holidays
will you be giving out halloween candy
what do we do thanksgiving christmas and
the other holidays
well martha i believe strongly that
particularly in the vaccinated people if
you're vaccinated and your family
members are vaccinated those who are
eligible and that is obviously very
young children are not yet eligible that
you can enjoy the holidays you can enjoy
halloween trick-or-treating and
certainly thanksgiving with your family
and christmas with your families that's
one of the reasons why we emphasize
why it's so important to get vaccinated
not only for your own safety for that of
your family but also for the good of the
community to keep the level of infection
down when you do that there's no reason
at all why you can't enjoy the holidays
in a family way the way we've
traditionally done it all along yeah you
know enjoying the holidays in a family
way the way we've done all along really
has nothing to do with listening to
people like him i get it he's probably
not a horrible person i don't know
what's going on with him at this point
like do i think he's a satan worshiper
and he's trying to destroy the west
possibly but i'm not fully saying that i
don't know what's going on with this man
i really don't
but if we are to believe that the
vaccines work let's say you want to go
home well i talked about halloween last
week because last week he had already
said you can do halloween so you know
we're allowed to go to strangers doors
they were telling us you know six foot
social distancing and you've got to
spray down your shopping bags and
everything else now you're allowed to go
to a stranger's door and take candy from
them okay and we know that people just
eat the candy right then the kids are
eating it but okay now that's okay right
even though as he said the youngest kids
aren't vaccinated of course what he
didn't say is that virtually no kids
have died of covid it's about 500 kids
.002 percent there's a lot of evidence
to show that those numbers are even
inflated and that they had all sorts of
other things that's not diminish any of
their lives okay got it
but now uh we can do thanksgiving but
let's think about it let's think about
it this way thanksgiving rolls around
let's he's saying if everyone's
vaccinated you're good to go well let's
say you have 10 people for thanksgiving
right and let's say you've got a crazy
right wing
freedom-loving libertarian don't tread
on me
cousin
right and that guy shows up and he's
probably smiling and he probably takes
care of himself too and he knows that
he's healthy and he shows up and i get
it he's right wing and he loves freedom
and america and he probably sent a
couple bucks to rand paul you know like
this is some nut bag but you know he
shows up and he's a pretty decent guy
and now you've all been vaccinated
why
would we think that he
would get everyone sick if you've all
been vaccinated can someone please
explain that to me i'm not a scientician
i'm not pretending that i'm one but can
someone explain that to me now first off
just because you aren't vaccinated it
doesn't mean you automatically have
covid that seems to be the new thing
that only vaccinated people can do
things but you're telling me that
otherwise young healthy people can't do
the things that they've always done how
does that make any sense i mean this is
exactly what kyrie irving the basketball
player is talking about jonathan isaac
from the nba these guys who are saying
hey i'm young and healthy like let's
just go about living our lives right was
kovitz spread at any nba games they
haven't shown us any evidence of that
but when he says that everyone has to be
vaccinated for you to get together it's
like you don't care about families
anthony fauci you don't care about
personal choice you don't care that
people might take their age and health
and all of those things into account
what you care about is you want to say
something and have
the minions do it and you're not a king
you're not even an elected official you
know like
i think people are just going to go and
do what they want and by the way
when when i say that do what you want
it's like
first off you should do what you want
you shouldn't listen to me other than
i'm trying to talk about freedom a
little bit which i know is a very scary
word it's the f word now you know
and it's like
you should take into account whether you
have a grandmother who's very old or
someone else in your family that's very
infirmed with something and all of those
things but again if the vaccines are to
work and they told us a hundred percent
they told us biden said once you're
vaccinated get out there live your life
and all that that was back in may june
and that is a perfect segue to this next
compilation video that's going making
the rounds on twitter so this is
spectacular you really need to watch
this we're going to show you about 80
seconds of it i think
it's about a two and a half minute video
of the full thing but we wanted to cut
it a little bit for brevity's sake here
this is over time
watching how fauci
talked about the efficacy of vaccines it
was a hundred percent up until where
it's at now so watch this it's it's
really really well done do we know who
made this because i want to credit them
properly we'll try to find it and put it
in the in the description uh it's really
spectacular so now we have two vaccines
that are really quite effective the mrna
vaccine highly effective extraordinarily
efficacious 94 to 95
for mild to moderate disease and
virtually 100 efficacious because the
real world effectiveness is even more
impressive than the results of the
clinical trial
[Music]
you might need another shot we've got to
make sure we clarify that with people it
has nothing to do with whether or not
it's effective
we know it's highly effective
i mean tell me that's just not
spectacular and that's why these people
want to censor the internet right like
that is exactly why they don't want us
to be able to make videos like that and
share videos like that